thank you all for coming and being brave
enough to stay until the slate so I'm
going to be talking about geometric
measures it's based on a sequence of
papers or joint work with zip bar Yoseph
ravi kumar and DC mack ahmad while we
were all together at IBM and since then
they decided to pursue greener pastures
literally Alex antoni who's here David
would refuse my colleague at idea
maldron and may have petruska who sadly
is not with us anymore and I would
dedicate this talk to him so so what is
information complexity so we have seen
in this workshop information complexity
being used to address two different
kinds of problems starting from
classical communication complexity say
the two-party case are to multiple
authorities number in hand as well as
air so add streaming models for example
so it's really hard to pin down a
mathematical definition of information
complexity and perhaps there is none but
nevertheless we can agree with this that
get you know it when you see it and I
let you google this and find out when
what context this was said ok so but
here sort of maybe a first good
definition at information complexity
it's still not mathematical but it
demonstrates the limitations of
computational models by bounding the
flow of information by some stretch of
imagination you can also think that this
applies to the extended formulations
where people wanted to lower bound the
size of these LPS so in any case if any
of you decides to write a monograph or a
survey please quote me on this so ok so
Alice and Bob ok so the last fifth day
of the workshop Alice and Bob have been
talking for a very long time
I mean bob has been talking but Alice my
god she's been just talking and talking
more often than ball so you see her like
me you know who came to us in the 90s
and was you know looking in to see what
does American culture represent so
probably for some of your world was
defined by the TV show Seinfeld so
perhaps you're thinking what happened in
one of these episodes which the famous
episode in which the phrase the worlds
are colliding we're a turd it's a very
good episode and so this is what this is
a conversation between Elaine and Susan
so yeah so even want Susan to join her
but she says you know all you guys able
to talk and talk and talking okay so
sore Allison both have been doing I'll
give you a few seconds to read it so
okay so right so you have at this point
Alice and Bob are tired and then perhaps
they are talking gibberish you know you
just want them to may the gods of
information till you forgive me we
wanted to shut up ok but no actually
what's happening really is that they are
actually conveying some information to
each other but it's much less than one
bit ok what could possibly be
interesting about that right and I think
for those people are familiar with these
things this is not a very surprising
thing so you can imagine the following
situation where it has been applied
repeatedly Alice involved use very few
bits of communications is now bits of
communication to solve a particular
problem and you want to show that this
is not possible so so that this implies
in many cases and indirect some or
whatever that they can actually solve a
subproblem in which they manage to
convey less than one bit of information
so that happens ok but actually we want
to show that this is impossible so we
want to prove lower bounds in this
setting and what I hope to show is that
this can be done
this is certainly one way to proceed
using the geometry of communication
protocols so you have seen in this
workshop information complexity being
used to up being applied to study
problems about geometry I mean in this
extended formulations but here I am
saying that I want to study I use
geometric measures and tools to prove
lower bounds for information complexity
so the motivation for me to give this
talk and by the way all these results
are approved in the last ten years or
not there is no recent results here but
when motivation for giving this talk is
that usually when I give a talk on these
direct some thing I start with locate a
big missionary information complexity to
a direct some simulation blah blah blah
and then you get to the part where you
want to prove this information
complexity of the small problem less
than one bit but nevertheless
interesting but then you think oh
actually I'll just throw something at it
and it will work and I don't really need
all this geometry stuff ok perhaps some
of you believe this at one point
probably still do so if you do then you
can leave the stock you don't have to
stay here and then I know who you are
but and I also believed it at one point
so but I think that there is something
interesting going on here and this talk
is an attempt to sort of maybe it'll
select that thing that dish we should
study this geometry more so I'll be for
those of you have seen this these types
of things this is more of like you know
a rehash of things but for some of you
it may be things that you have not seen
because you never get to look at that
part in in most of the presentations at
least so okay so it's going to be a
lightweight talk I I wish I thought
about the laugh speaker so i would just
finish early and you guys will be happy
with me but maybe I kind of ramble on
like this and fill the time okay
okay so good so let me start by
describing the Tran how we get to this
geometry so this is the notion of a
transcript wavefunction a fancy name for
something very very simple so when you
have a particular protocol you can then
say pie for enzyme studying only in the
two-party setting for now that PI of X Y
is the probability distribution the sort
to work over transcripts on input pie on
and x1 and particular input X Y so the
cord the coordinate corresponding to tau
represents a probability that the
transcript equals tau so this is a
vector that lies in the unit simplex of
the sum of these values is one but it's
not such an interesting geometry there
in the l1 space and we know a far richer
thing and we move to the l2 space so how
do we actually do this so we take each
of these probabilities and just take the
square root so that just moves it from
the unit simplex to the unit sphere
particularly in the positive ortant so
now we have some geometry that you can
study with this and that's essentially
this notion of failing your distance
which basically is a scaled version of
the Euclidean distance between the
transcript wave functions the name was
an attempt to appeal to the quantum
folks I don't know if I secreted sum of
the squares of these things is one so
the heading a distance is basically the
the l2 distance including distance
between these two transcript wave
functions scaled by a particular
parameters to make sure that it's always
between 0 and 1 and so it just seems
like a notational switch but I actually
want to think in distance because I
think it helps us also to build better
notions that is that I want to think of
this as actually defining a new distance
not a distance between inputs so you
have two inputs X Y X prime Y Prime i'm
actually using this distance between the
transcript wave functions to
this is the distance real distance
between these two points okay the wave
functions are defined with respect to a
particular protocol place yes the
protocol is fixed yes oh so these are
inputs and I'm inducing some kind of
distance between them based on a fixed
protocol the protocol defines that
distance so there are different protocol
would define a different distance right
so I am yeah I am NOT going across
protocols I am just looking at the
geometry of this for a fixed protocol
okay so transfer also because this is
now and this is true even in the l1
space but now you are in the alley to
space and also it still they induce a
metric on the input space so you get
things like triangle inequality which is
nice to work with so that's already some
kind of geometry but of all more
interesting geometry you get when you
actually look at the square of B of this
distance of this the Euclidean distance
and this leads to some very interesting
theory the square of the Euclidean
distances forms belongs to this class of
distance basis set distance base not a
metric space called a negative type
distance space classic reference for
this is design and Laurent and it plays
a very important role in the theory of
metric and weddings and so there are
lots of the interesting theorems that
one can show here in this theory I mean
just shown books theorem which is one of
the classics in this area but you can
even get quite a bit with simple theorem
so for our for all purposes and this is
one reason i believe that you really
sort of scratch the surface because i
have you are able to do already so much
with these simple types of things so
this inequality says that you know if
you have a sap bunch of coefficients
that sum up to 0 then this inequality
always holds for any set of vectors DV
is okay right so are consequences of
this are you get you know nice
inequalities so my convention is that
the in these inequalities the the bigger
side will be denoted by red and the
smaller side will be denoted by glue to
the extent i can stay with this
convention so this star inequality says
that if you sum up the red edges and by
what i mean by that is take the distance
squared then it's greater than or equal
to the sum of the blue distance there
are blue edges and so this is the star
inequality the five here oh there is a
constant that we will have to put here
if there are s vertices here then you
put one over s this other thing is
something also on a quadrilateral it
says that the four edges the sum of them
is at least the sum of the blue edges
this is also called the short diagonals
lemma and this already has a very
interesting consequence that the Hamming
cube in two dimensions cannot be
embedded isometrically into the
euclidean space and once you then
approve by induction basically you take
these inequalities the proposition gives
a particular type of inequality and then
you look at the cone of all these
inequalities and one such inequality in
this cone would be the thing that says
that the the Hamming cube in n
dimensions just not isometric lay embed
into Euclidean space and in fact it
suffers a significant amount of
distortion so that's a result due to n
flow but it has a simple proof using
these types of inequalities oh can this
will be these two illustrated these two
because they show up in in in the
information reflects t as well okay so
so far okay so we have now we know that
this negative type space you get a rich
class of inequalities and I want to say
that fine we also get additional
properties because we are dealing with
the whatever this transcript
wavefunctions induced by particular
protocol so and these properties will
come purely by the rectangular structure
of protocols which has been referred to
one in which you have seen some of the
earlier talks so one of these is the z
lemma which says that this diagonal is
at least the sum
of these two blue things and you
probably have the sum of these two blue
things and this other X lemma which says
that actually these two diagonals are
actually equal so I want to emphasize
that these are not properties that you
would get from any particular you know
embedding where the embedding coming
from communication protocols okay so of
course the point is that when you look
at these types of inequalities they're
just some labels some bunch of points
some of them are called as red edges and
some of them are called as blue edges
it's more interesting if you can
actually associate some kind of meaning
with these particular you know things
that are being connected by blue edges
and things are being connected by red
edges and that comes from looking at
particular metric spaces so I want to
tell you something about inequalities
that come from metric spaces and that
connects to this that was motivated by
looking at this following problem which
is becoming a tu parte communication
problem this is the distance estimation
in general matrix so Alice and Bob get a
pair of inputs from some metric space
with the promise that they either the
distance is far some parameter T or
clothes and you want to prove an
information complexity lower bound for
this problem so so this is what led us
to consider beat these types of you know
inequalities is also a negative type
inequality but holds only for this thing
metric a particular metric spaces and
it's referred to as a point karyotype
inequality so it doesn't hold all the
time so you have to design one derive
one such thing so the definition is as
follows you have a particular
distribution distribution a 20 on
clothes instances another distribution a
tie one on for instances and you have a
parameter lambda you say that a point
carry inequality holds for this metric
space if no matter how um by dem into L
2 so this is what i mean by labeling the
points em by the induced embedding in l2
if the following inequality holds that
they expected
in a squared euclidean distance under
this embedding for clothes instances is
at least lambda times the corresponding
thing for four instances and this
inequality sort of seems to be going the
wrong way counter-intuitively because
it's pulling close things on the on the
bigger side but that's precisely the
point because this is being used to
prove non embed ability so you want to
say in some sense that even the clothes
points accumulate enough distance in
under the embedding so then you cannot
hope to keep the 44 points farther apart
under the same bedding okay so examples
of such this thing so on the line metric
this is just points in 2 0.0 through D
and if you this is just comes from
applying Cauchy Schwarz that you look at
the close ones are the ones that are
adjacent on the integer line from 0
through D and the only farthest point is
0 and m and you get 1 over d as the
lambda of the constant the point correct
constant wide radius I should mention
that that particular quantity is
actually computable for a case this
graph metrics through the well-known
connection well-known SDP that actually
can compute it and I can sort of jump
ahead and say that that sdp is the one
that actually four graphs computes the
spectral gap and therefore for expanders
you get a pointer inequality with lambda
equal to the normalized spectral cap on
the Hamming cubed is the one that I
mentioned earlier that you can prove one
such version inequality just through you
know simple arguments technically taking
the short diagonals limo and doing an
induction type argument a more sort of
involved type of point type of
inequality is the one proved by Alex by
Anthony and robocode grammar who do dig
this for edit distances and so there are
a lot more I am just not listed all of
them here so I hope that these things
will play a role in the kinds of
communication complexity bones we want
to prove so the theorem that we showed
was that in fact you can prove an
information complexity lower bound of
lambda
is one such version that we proved I
mean there are some small variance to
this so right at the heart of this
particular theorem after you go through
all the standard missionary of the
direction theorem it's just a very
simple negative type inequality for
distances induced by communication
protocols and that is the following so
it is this type of inequality so let me
pass this for you so you are going to
pick a pair of inputs to Alice and Bob
according to a 20 this is the one where
the point carry inequality says they are
closed and you are looking at in one
case giving you to Allison you to Bach
and in the other case giving you to
alice + v2 bomb so these are pairs of
inputs but nevertheless they are still
closed because either the distance is 0
or because it was picked from a 2-0
they're closed right on the other side
we are looking at UV picked according to
8 a 1 this is the far pair and in this
case we are measuring the distance
between you you and UV well this
distance is still 0 but you will speak
according to the for distribution so
these represent in some sense far things
in this communication problem ok and
what we show is that this kind of
inequality holds for those embeddings
there's a lot of things buried in here
and I say the distance between this and
this I am fixing a particular protocol
and looking at the corresponding
transcript wave function and looking at
the l2 distance defined by that
particular protocol so this is a
protocol specific inequality and it
works only for communication protocols
so let me just prove this the proof is
just three lines and then I have just
one more slide after that ok so right
so you start with something which looks
slightly different than what I had in
the earlier slide because in the earlier
slide I have just one expression here
now i'm going to put two expressions
this is something that i can do by
symmetrization i won't get into the
details so you have u uu v that was one
of the stones there but i'm also adding
UV and vb so that the first coordinate
also changed right ok so now so yeah I
have a an animation going on the right
side you can see what's happening so you
just first apply this week triangle
inequality which means that i can
replace the two red edges by this red
edge and i want you to follow us as we
go along as to where we are looking at
clothes pairs and four pair so so so far
we are only looking at clothes pairs
this is all closed UV speak from a 20
and still you you too v.v it still too
close pairs and now the here's the thing
i can do is that now i can think oh ok
so i do have a point karyotype
inequality where I associate ucumar you
as the embedding of the point you ok and
we come out we as the embedding of the
point V this sort of similar to I think
hard modes talk in which he was looking
at the diagonal points so this is some
doing some similar thing maybe there's
some superficial similarity or maybe
something deeper I don't know and I saw
your talk I was sort of struck by it so
yeah so you're just looking at a
diagonal point so now you can save each
of this I can think of as the embedding
of the point you right and therefore i
can apply the pointer a type inequality
to move so there's look at these things
they should be exactly the same except
that now from a 20 i moved to a tower
one from clothes too far and of course i
have to put this constant lambda in for
the pointer type inequality ok ok so
that's now this edge now this is wrong I
mean I made a mistake because this is
still this
still should be at red hy because we
have moved no doubt from you from a 202
801 but look at the two points they're
still of distance zero right so the two
pairs of inputs being compared or really
still close instances right and I mean
understandably the shunt of work but
it's no point because i have not used
any property of communication protocols
I've just used point karyotype
inequality triangle inequality and you
are indeed what you need to do is apply
this Z lemma that says that I can lower
bound this diagonal by v2 in a
horizontal edges here now at this point
you see that you achieved what you
wanted which is that this is this pair
you you and UV represents a close pair
and a far pair because UV is coming from
8 a 1 and a similar thing there so and
then you have to do some symmetrization
at the end so to get the inequality
directly into it so that is it basically
ok so this net basically this negative
type inequality is really at the heart
of the proof for matrix that gives you
all the tight lower bounds for some
streaming problems ok so I want to
conclude with this one more slide after
this but let me say that you can also
derive some kind of negative type
inequality 4k player number in hand
protocols I should have mentioned that
so that we parse this notation for you
so let K be a power of 2 so there are
two to the art players and I want to
look at the following setting where the
inputs can be identified with points on
the Hamming cube of dimension D so you
have so you need to be able to map your
inputs into points on the hanukkah I
mean they can actually be the input stem
cells that you know indeed for the K
part is each player gets a zero or
exactly one of them gets a one or I mean
I can get anything is up there is
nothing about promise nothing here is
like
any regular protocol and but it's also
applies to other situations where you
have other sets of inputs but you can do
this mapping so in that case it says
that basically this if I think of these
as close pairs because they
corresponding to edges in the Hamming
cube and these are far one single fault
pair then I get an inequality of this
type so this constant C is some constant
I and it turns out to be interestingly
related to something that oil or studied
in the context of integer partitions
it's called the digital search tree
constant so I mean how often do you come
up with Euler in communication protocols
so you can I mean good territory here so
that's cool okay so that's all basically
I had to say let me conclude that you
can usually take these information
complexity arguments and I are direct
some argument proved tight communication
complexity lower bounds for different
problems but that directs a mark that
uses chain rule but interestingly in all
these applications you can replace this
chain rule also by appropriate distances
in the Euclidean space when you're doing
some kind of tensor ization but but you
can live entirely in the geometry
induced by these communi geometry of
distances induced by communication
protocols it's their little maybe the
chain rule thing looks nicer but in
particular you have to extend pairwise
distances there's one which is what I
have been dealing with to looking at
distances between collections of points
and this might seem like an artifact
that I introduced for this for this
because I wanted to live in this space
and not use chain rule but there are
other problems that I have encountered
the same thing and there is not an issue
of you know trying to fake a chain rule
by by geometric structure there's truly
something going on in these other
problems that I don't understand because
they involve combinations of points and
distances we have to reconstruct this
thing but it seemed quite hairy that I
sort of gave up so so I believe that
this theory is still in its nascent
stage
agent it requires maybe some smarter
thinking but I hope you know some of you
will take up on it thank you
so is there something maybe that can be
done in the opposite direction so
there's a lot of about the problems
about metric spaces or is it too
specialized to this structure right so
there is this connection that I think
Alex and his quarters have been pursuing
which is to take communication protocols
and say something about metric
embeddings themselves I don't need it
goes in the direction of proving lower
bounds but it does say that you can take
so there are some new results along
these lines so but one has to check if
it's going in the direction that you are
interested in so there's a new paper by
Alex Roby and Helia which is going to
appear in stock just provide support us
and there's a nice blog post about this
letter leah has written to so what
looking at it in this space the thing
that I have been stuck on and I guess
you have we have all been stuck one
including mean earlier discussions with
use the hand or tree so we know that the
decision tree a lower bound for that
problem is tight it's a balanced tree of
you know log and depth with n leaves
with alternating levels of hand and are
so we know the exact you know decision
tree complexity of this problem but if
you just replace if you just put you
know labels of these by x1 y1 x2 y2 and
so on the best lower bond that we know
are is I think root and just by the fact
that you can have an instance of set dis
join us in it on route and inputs but we
don't know anything better than that and
it is in this context that when we were
trying to do information complexity that
we ran into some really hairy measures
that we didn't know how to bond so that
would be one thing the second thing I
would mention is nothing is known about
the kinds of problems where you have a
fork like structure right you solve some
problems even
classic for problem in the car
Smallville person game you solve some
problem and based on that you either go
left or right it's some kind of binary
search thing and I don't send that I
that has to do with more about enhancing
I think direct some to deal with these
types of things as to when you have
conditionals in world so I don't know if
that can be tackled directly through
geometry but certainly direct some
arguments are didn't seem to give us
anything we tried
you